sad news about clay though
all right so what should we talk about
today
cory unhinged
so if you want to understand why
fascists get into politics it's never
more clear
than when you hear it from the fascist
it's not just because they were too weak
for sports or too ugly for showbiz
although that explains adam's schiff
it's to gain power
over you and become exempt from the
rules they enforce on others
it's why as a kid every wanted to be
everybody wanted to be simon
in a game of simon says it's like
becoming a narc who sells cocaine or a
new york governor with faster hands than
a blackjack dealer
but then there's corey bush this fiery
ball of hypocrisy makes maxine waters
sound like mahatma gandhi here she is
telling voters
that they're going to get fewer cops on
the beat but she's going to get more
security than a brinks truck
i won't let them get that off you can't
get that off i'm going to make sure i
have security because i know
i have had attempts on my life and i
have too much work to do there are too
many people
that need help right now for me to allow
that so if
i end up spending 200 000 if i spend 10
10 10 more dollars on it you know what i
get to be here to do the work
so suck it up and defunding the police
has to happen we
need to defund the police and put that
money into social safety nets
wow i thought we weren't defunding the
police that's what the dems were saying
if this woman were any more unhinged
she'd be the screen door on a trailer
and a tornado
she basically just said i'm powerful
i get the protection you don't and
unlike you she has private security
because her body is worth
being on this planet right now i have
private security because my body
is worth being on this planet right now
i have private security
because they the white supremacists
racist narrative that they drive into
this country
the fact that they don't care that this
black woman that has put her life on the
line
true her life is worth it but the same
could be said for all those owners of
bodegas and clothing stores that were
burned looted or otherwise destroyed in
the riots
or how about all the black and brown
casualties arising from this relentless
crime wave
egged on by her defunding idiocy but who
knows maybe she'll start making some
sense
what other occupation can do work that's
out of their scope
and still be propped up to do work
that's out of their scope
as a nurse i can't be the surgeon too
you don't want me being your surgeon and
i'm the nurse
at what point do we pay police to be
social workers
no we don't how do they get to be social
workers
the sound of a bird flying into a wheat
thresher makes more sense
bottom line she's saying she deserves
protection and you don't
at least when the mafia shakes you down
you get some security in return
they don't leave you at the mercy of
other gangs and then brag about it
i am not sure you can find a truer
version of fascism taking shape if you
watched home movies of mussolini
for an order for the radical to assume
power they must follow these three key
steps
undermine the stability of institutions
that keep us secure
claim they are for equality for the
people then gain power and assume
authority minus the previous safeguards
for citizens
suddenly their promise of equality
evaporates and the police that they so
vilified
now works for them only meet the new
boss
worse than the old boss because this
boss has no interest in actual equality
only punishment of course this is the
same lady who vowed revenge against the
mccloskey couple
after the missouri governor pardoned
them after they pled guilty to
misdemeanors
after pointing guns at trespassing blm
protesters
mark mccloskey is an absolute liar he
has spat on my name
and and because of that his day his day
will come
he spat on my name his day will come
that's personal sentiment coming from a
politician about a private citizen
seems a little crazed the threat is
clear insult one of your rulers and
there will be hell to pay
it's like game of thrones without the
brother or sister marriage
unless you're ilhan omar now
now you see why private citizens are
buying guns it's like snow shovels the
day before a nor'easter
you have unhinged politicians who don't
need to buy guns surrounded by folks who
have them
threatening citizens who realize the
second amendment might be the only
protection they have
they've already shut down the first
amendment and they're working their way
through the list
they're like brian stelter eating his
way through the menu at mcdonald's
now bush claims she gets death threats
and i don't doubt it if you're in the
public eye
that's a certainty i get him regularly
almost always from the same email
address
but at least you know at least
at least cat has the decency to threaten
me in person
but do i have a full security detail no
well yes if you count my yellow belt and
slap fighting from tiger shulman's
so it's getting weird the radicals are
no longer in the streets
spitting at cops destroying property
they're now in office
they're making changes and they're
taking names they're protected
you aren't it's not the end of the world
but what's that look like anyway
does it all come at once or in dribs and
drabs radicals are really good at this
stuff
they know america is a distracted and
ambivalent gulliver
in the land of lillyput addicted to
their screens
while we scrolled they strolled right in
and they tied us down
while we got fat and relaxed glued to
twitter and tick tock the rads overtook
teachers lounges hr departments
government
and the only thing standing between us
and these petty tyrants
is a daughtering president whose only
passion is ice cream
it's time to put the phone down and
start stepping up it's time to get as
pissed off as they are
playing candy crush or words with
friends ain't going to cut it anymore
[Applause]
welcome tonight's kiss if you want to
get the jasper you got to go through her
first america's newsroom co-anchor and
the five co-hosts data
burrito
she's called out more bullcrap than a
janitor at a rodeo
fox news channel anchor julie berderas
even porn stars thinks his name sounds
made up it's [ __ ] sexton
and she's like a spider wiry and fast
but also eat bugs and lives under your
bed
fox news contributor cat tim
so dana welcome to the show welcome it's
great to see you it feels like i just
saw you already
all right so clearly uh you know what
she says a lot of stuff
this lady so she is going to get death
threats but we all get death threats
we all want to have security why is her
security more important than the people
she represents i mean it might be hard
to believe but even i get death threats
i know i mean who how would they dare i
don't know well stuart varney is still
pissed off at you
i know i know so do you remember when
the democrats went after republicans for
saying that you're all like todd aiken
remember that guy todd aiken
remember that this way back when you
remember buck okay
and i'm aching for an explanation bad
guy bad guy like not a good candidate
and not representative of everybody in
the republican party
i think the democrats anybody who said
that the republicans are all like todd
aiken
are going to have a very hard time
saying that she doesn't represent them
right because but kevin mccarthy the
majority leader
for the republicans he just got got to
sit back today and watch a campaign ad
being made
right and just yesterday you had the
head of the democrats
saying guys we have a big problem the
election were held today we would lose
and here's one of the reasons why
defund the police doesn't work well
actually she's like hold my beer
i will make it all better for you and
now they are looking at some really
bad it's not just bad politics obviously
it's terrible outcomes as well
but their politics are absolutely
terrible yeah yeah and it was we were
told
by everybody that the funding the police
wasn't really defined no he's a
republican remember
remember the president biden and the
white house press secretary tried to say
that it was actually republicans who
were for defunding the police and
finally the washington post gave them
three pinocchios it should have been 20.
so julie uh welcome to the show um
lovely to be here
i don't believe you but i'm gonna i want
to put this uh story in an analogy that
you'll understand
oh god this is like saying crystal meth
should be illegal
except for me because i'm a leader and
this helps me deal with my stress
wow all right so crystal meth is not
legal just so you know what happened
tonight it's not but
i thought it was interesting she opened
my whole eyes up to this i don't know
about everybody at home but first of all
i had no idea you could get security for
ten dollars
which that means that cat might be able
to afford it and
here in new york city we don't need guns
we had bricks at the blm
protest yeah that's true and those are
pretty cheap too so i think
in the end i think we can look back and
say if you have a gun great because
she has security detail which i believe
are armed
but i mean if you think about the people
that were at these blm protests that
actually trespassed on the property of
the mccloskeys
and they did not get charged so where is
cory bush's upro
roar on that oh i can't believe they
didn't get charged for trespassing but
they can't stand there with a gun and if
they hadn't stood there with the gun
they're probably going to be robbed or
looted like what's there right
cory was actually she was at that
protest yes yes yes and i'm not
saying that she was throwing bricks but
let's just say that these blm protesters
are not
all peaceful exactly as we know you were
um pretty much run out of town in new
york city yeah right i was hiding in the
bushes
yes not the best phrase at this point
but i was i know my wife was hiding in
the scaffolding and i was hiding
somewhere in westchester
doing something legal somewhere
obviously very very legal
at least in some parts of the world buck
welcome to the show good to see you not
walking your dog in your pajamas
changing it up yes so what do you make
of this is this just
i hate saying that politicians are
hypocrite
hypocrites because that's like saying
water is wet
we get it we understand it but this is a
kind of breaking new ground
it's amazing because defund the police
is if you were trying to hold a contest
for the dumbest political slogan
you could possibly come up with i think
this would be pretty high up there
it's so nonsensical it's like getting
people to march in the streets saying
let's all smash
ourselves in the face with frying pans
it doesn't make any sense
and we've seen the results of it now
right now we've seen what's happened in
cities across the country
it's not surprising at all but i've said
corey bush first of all
amazing those clips i feel like i'm
interrupting what we could have which is
just more corey bush clips because it's
fantastic to hear what she has to say on
it
but you know there's maya wiley here in
new york you said they say they don't
want to defund police
they actually there are some on the left
who say no no we mean actually cut
police budgets they did it in
minneapolis they did it in austin
they've done it in a number of cities
maya wiley though happens to live in a
roughly three million dollar mansion in
brooklyn
that wait for it pays for private
security
in her neighborhood so not a victim
workers
not social workers she ain't calling the
social workers i
i'm gonna be a hypocrite cat i actually
i think she would be a barrel of laughs
to hang out with for some reason
i agree would be i would hang out with
her
and i feel like i would leave loving
myself so deeply
yes um but i am confused uh
just because she is a self-described
loud and proud democratic socialist
right
right but uh you know removing
fun government funding for police and
having citizens fund their own
private security is an
anarcho-capitalist position
right that is literally the ana
anarcho-capitalist
model for law enforcement so
i am confused by that yes i'm confused
as a democratic socialist
how are you having apparently an uh
anarcho-capitalist lifestyle
i'm also confused is she a nurse or a
doctor
or a surgeon it took me a while to
figure out the analogy and what she was
saying is you can't have police officers
doing two different roles right was that
what she meant that's what she did but
they actually are doing
lots of roles all the time yeah they
bring up because they say well we need
auxiliaries to do more of the roles that
they can't do because they're already
doing the roles
and then your head explodes they want to
send social workers to domestic violence
he also did not get a social worker
detail i would also say that
mental health workers tend not to want
to show up to really frightening
situations without a law enforcement
officer
there because that can get scary exactly
and on that note this show is far from
scary hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else